normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government will
scotus intervene in Illinois assault
weapons case this is big news this could
uh look let me just first start the
segment by saying we're winning I think
more than half the country is already in
some form constitutional carry though
Florida only allows concealed carry
without a permit you can't open carry
which is interesting but I think more
than half the country something like
what 26 States it's now constitutional
carrying meaning if you live in the
state you got an ID you can walk into a
gun store you can say I'd like to
purchase a gun fill out the federal
background check form once you clear you
can buy the gun you don't need a permit
from the state however they're trying to
ban assault weapons and as we learned in
the documentary infringed that just came
out nobody even knows what that means it
has no Universal definition and anybody
who knows anything about guns knows
there is no such thing as an assault
weapon somewhat similar to the what is
the woman documentary we went around and
we like interviewed everyone so what
what is an assault weapon and that is
the right conclusion we came to not a
single person could Define it it it
works to their advantage right because
in in in Biden State of the Union you
know um he was talking about uh shooting
that happen with a handgun yeah and then
you know at you know at the end he goes
ban assault weapons now okay but you
just talked about a handgun people
semi-automatic hand people don't
understand that and and thankfully for
it but the people that are anti-gun for
a long time haven't haven't wanted to
educate themselves about guns and what's
unfortunate and what they're starting to
learn Now is really what they're after
is semi-automatic because that's what so
so so so first I'm assuming 99% of
people who watch the show know what
semi-automatic means it means when you
pull the trigger a single bullet comes
out yeah you had that great clip in
infringed of Michael Bloomberg saying
semi- automato they pull the trigger
back and it just goes not true let me
read this from bearing arms it's
important they say today's Supreme Court
arguments focused on the federal
prohibition on Firearms Poss for those
subject to a domestic violence
restraining order and in the months
ahead of the ahead the court will hear
cases involving the atf's
administratively imposed ban on bump
stocks as well as a First Amendment case
brought by the National Rifle
Association against a New York a New
York official that the group contends
illegally pressured private companies
not to work with the organization
they're going to say that uh now 2A
activists in the Land of Lincoln are
ready to try their luck of the Supreme
Court once again this time after the
seventh Circuit Court of Appeals
recently overturned an injunction and
allowed the state's ban on so-called
assault weapons and large capacity
magazines to be enforced in their
decision the three judge panel concluded
that AR-15s and other arms labeled quote
assault weapons by Illinois lawmakers
are not protected by the Second
Amendment at all because semi-automatic
rifles are like machine guns which the
court declared are not protected weapons
in the hel decision the actual phrasing
was weap weapons that are most useful in
military service M16 rifles and the like
the Supreme Court has also said that
arms that are in common use for lawful
purposes are protected this could be big
this could mean that we finally end this
stupid fake assault weapon argument
there is no such thing as an assault
weapon Now by all means if they wanted
to draft a simple statement as to what
an assault weapon was let's hear it the
issue assault weapon is a nebulous term
intentionally used to scare people to
try and gain control exactly and you saw
this with like the Cody Wilson interview
the ghost Gunner right where he talks
about how the ATF are constantly playing
this cat and mouse game with him with
just the definition of a a gun a rifle
in general he's like in order to
restrict and control us they want to
make the polymer like that has to be a
gun the primordial form then he creates
just a block the 0% Receiver right now
the ATF is going to have to designate
that a gun in order to track that down
and they will they will keep changing
the definition cuz they want to be able
to control it at all costs possible 0%
re okay so it's a metal block it's just
it's just a rectangle of metal and a CNC
machine which basically Cuts metal can
cut it into a receiver yeah it's a
desktop CNC machine that they make at
ghost Gunner that you can buy and then
they you know if if if if if you want to
if you want to manufacture if you want
if you're interested if you want to
manufacture a lower receiver with it
they will send you the aluminum in the
mail and you just put it into the CNC
and the story here is that uh companies
used to sell what's called an 80% which
is not a complete gun but it's
components of and the ATF said no no
because people can make a gun with it
it's a gun officially so ghost Gunner
just sells blocks and then the the issue
here is it's actually first amendment
that 3D printed guns are just knowledge
the knowledge or the file the document
that can make the weapon information the
issue is that uh uh 3D Printing and at
at home CNC cutting metal and stuff it's
it's cheap and ubiquitous so this is the
one of the big challenges that 3D
printed guns the cats out of the bag man
yeah exactly can't stop the signal it's
going to be crazy when they start like
registering USB drives as guns and I I
will say unironically unironically
exactly everybody should uh definitely
be get safety training you know don't
take this stuff lightly I just read a
crazy story where some guy in Brazil was
goof was was was goofing off like a
and his girlfriend was filming him
laughing and he pointed a gun at her and
now she is no longer alive guns see this
is the thing I feel like when Alec
Baldwin killed that woman uh Hela H
Helena Hutchins with a gun the left
defended him saying it's not his fault
and I'm like the craziest thing in the
world to me is that the gun control
people are saying a dude who pointed a
loaded weapon at a woman and killed her
had live ammo in his belt it's not his
fault and all of the gun control people
are like you are responsible for
whatever comes out of the barrel of a
gun you are holding it's I'm like how
are the gun control people excusing this
guy there are four rules and that's it
at the end of the day there are four
rules keep your finger straighten off
the trigger never point a gun at
anything that you don't that you
wouldn't destroy treat every gun as if
it's loaded and know your Target and
what's behind it at all times if you
follow those rules no one dies period
well well sometimes well I mean if you
no one dies be by mistake the point is
those are basic rules that you're taught
immediately all the time to dramatically
minimize stupidity which results in
people getting seriously hurt however
but let's just be real you need to
understand and respect firearms because
misfires happen like instructors
sometimes have issues uh there's a lot
of things that can go wrong no one no
one hates bad gun users more than other
gun users because they ruin it for
everyone no no one will be more
outspoken against the Alec Baldwins of
the world than you know the the donut
operators and the Brandon Herrera who
want you to use your guns properly just
put a picture on Up of you holding a gun
with poor Trigger Discipline with your
finger on and you're going to hear about
it forever forever forever exactly live
correctly when I was in
Egypt uh we had to go to the state media
building to get press cards so that you
wouldn't get arrested for being there to
walk into the State Building they have
armed guards standing on both sides of
the of the walled entrance and these
people do not have what is referred to
as muzzle discipline they're holding all
their weapons like this and so you so I
limbo I'm just like bro that 18-year-old
Egyptian dude holding an AK straight up
at head level I would rather limbo and
have them laugh than like walk past that
dude you know what I'm saying yeah I got
the internet I seen what happens most
people just didn't care and they walked
past him and I'm just like I'm going to
go like this and loop my head around cuz
uh but you have awareness around
Firearms like you are watching you
understand and that's even if someone
doesn't want own a firearm having an
understanding of how they work is a
pretty damn critical skill tumbling
tumbling you see all these clips like
you know they'll uh you know they will
pull a trigger and the shot doesn't go
off and then they're like oh what's
wrong and then they look down the
barrel don't do that no weapons no I I I
want I want to stress the Alec baldon
thing they're saying they might they may
bring charges again
but just understand this when these
liberal people want to defend Alec
Baldwin simply because he's a liberal
that listen just understand this this is
what we try to call out the dude had
reportedly live bullets in his gun belt
on his person he had a he had a single
there was a single action revolver so
you got to pull the hammer back and then
you got to pull the trigger he lied
about pulling the trigger there was a a
friends conclusion that the trigger had
to have been depressed the only way that
it would have fired there was a live
round in the chamber I say outright if
you are handed a gun and it can fire
bullets you are responsible for what
comes out of the end of it even if it's
a blank yeah exactly blank kill people
right and they don't they don't
understand this and the argument Alec
Baldwin said was if I were to have
opened it to check they would have
rushed over and taken it from me for
tampering with it and I'm like no sense
Hollywood is broken if they are handing
random people weapons that those people
have not checked do do don't follow
those policies that that gets people
hurt and we saw it with Alec Baldwin
there are did a few videos on this and
there are um rules within like the
actor's guild and uh set workers and you
can go and read them and they're pretty
standardized most people know them and
it says both the uh weapons Handler and
the actor is supposed to check so I
don't know if if he said that that's
insane because that's a pretty standard
you can talk to any weapons expert in
Hollywood and they all will affirm
like upet that is never okay yeah that
blows my mind how does that happen right
I can't even imagine how that happened
they claim that people were goofing off
and and shooting cans with the guns you
are going to be using on set I'm sorry
what it is it is it is insane to me you
get all these liberals being like it's
not his fault he's just an actor and I'm
it's that mentality right it's not
hypocrisy it's it's hierarchy exactly
what are Hollywood people doing shooting
cans on their spare time anyway thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net